so who's my guest this week the data
scientist and facebook whistleblower
francis haugen
is the personal cost outweighed by the
wider good this is the whistleblower's
dilemma
francis haugen calls her decision to go
public with what she discovered working
at facebook not plan a not even plan b
but plan j
but if it wasn't her initial intention
it's now become central to her life
sharing tens of thousands of internal
documents with the media and u.s law
enforcement
she wanted to show that metta facebook's
parent company knew the harm it was
causing and carried on regardless
the firm says haugen's claims paint a
false picture and it makes no commercial
sense to allow harmful content as
advertisers don't want it
but you can only really whistle blow
once so what happens next and how do you
keep up the pressure for change when
you're now an outsider
here's what's coming up do you think of
facebook as having blood on his hands
yes unquestionably um facebook's own
documents say
instagram isn't just bad for teenagers
it's not just bad for children it's not
just bad for them it's actually worse
than other forms of social media because
tick tock is about performance it's
about humor it's about doing things with
your friends
snapchat is about faces about augmented
reality
reddit is at least nominally about ideas
right but instagram is about bodies and
social comparison
francis thank you so much for being here
for talking to me today and to all of us
thank you for inviting me happy to be
here well i mean you your voice has
become very famous indeed i wanted to
start by asking how it's been since
you've gone public as a whistleblower
you know it's so interesting um i live
in in puerto rico and uh no one ever
recognizes me there and i've been i've
been really shocked at like in some ways
my life has changed a lot right like i
can sleep now at night so that's always
a good thing um i do interviews like
this which is still surreal to me um but
you know
it's enough separated from like san
francisco that you know i'm never
recognized in that context and so my
life hasn't really changed that much on
a day-to-day basis
i'm amazed that i can have my dms open
online like you can dm me on twitter and
like i don't even get harassed um and so
i know that compared to like female
politicians i've had an easy experience
how's it going
has that changed was it different when
you first went public oh no and even
when i first went public okay i've gone
i've gotten like maybe
maybe 10 mean messages ever
um and like i always respond to them so
what do you tell me what's your
technique yeah um i don't know i'm
always willing to talk to my critics and
how do they usually calm down a bit at
that point they usually don't respond
you know
who'd have thought they'd be rude hey um
but but that's interesting you also say
now you can sleep at night we are not
sleeping when you worked at facebook um
it's really hard living with a secret
you know like uh i think one thing i had
never really contemplated before i came
out was was
whistleblowers in general are not in
very good shape by the time they come
out and like one of the things that i
had that i think was very different
about my experience versus most people's
is i lived with my parents during coven
and so i had people who i completely
trusted who i could talk to things about
and so by the time like i came out or by
the time i acted like i was already
aligned with like what i needed to do
and i think for a lot of people who are
whistleblowers they live alone with a
secret where they know people's lives
are on the line
and that process really eats away at you
and um
you know i i know that i did what i
could and so there's there's a wonderful
uh release in that right it's very easy
to sleep at night then but i suppose
with that i mean and you were not
sleeping you were stressed about what
you knew we'll get into that
did you need a certain level of grit
resilience to actually go through with
it would you say because of course you
know there are different types of
whistleblower in different circumstances
oh and unquestionably we actually i
think it's a society need to talk more
about the continuum of whistleblowing
like in the united states you know you
can't sign a contract that prevents you
from giving information to congress that
you believe is necessary for congress to
do oversight
um you can be a very subtle quiet
whistleblower it's just that people see
the few whistleblowers that are out
and so i think it's one of these things
where if you know that what you need to
do is necessary
um you know i've always been a
long-distance cyclist you know you just
put on more miles you know just keep
going
and um
i'm really happy with how things ended
up were you scared just before you know
what was that moment like i don't even
know what the moment was yeah that you
blew the whistle so i think there's like
different sets of moments so um while i
was getting the information out of
facebook i was very worried that i i
wouldn't be able to get out the
information that was needed
right that i i i
knew that this was very complicated
that if you didn't get a representative
set of documents that you know you could
um criticize it and say this is not this
is not a full picture um and so until i
was done i was very nervous that i would
not finish
but i never worried about consequences
because like the number of lives that
are on the line is is is astronomical
right like i earnestly believe there are
10 or 20 million lives on the line in
some of the most fragile places in the
world when you say on the line what do
you mean so so far we've had two major
um ethnic violence instances genocides
that were they were facilitated by
social media so i had one in myanmar
where over 200 000 people died we've had
another one in ethiopia over the last
couple of years
and we should not expect that to be the
end we should expect that to be the
beginning
and what's the difference between using
social media to organize and using i
don't know email
oh i'm so glad you asked that's a
wonderful question um so in email the
the service provider in general is not
telling you what order to read your
email in right there are not algorithms
that give distribution to some ideas and
not to others
in the case of facebook um the algorithm
changes they made in 2018 to go from
just trying to keep you on the site as
long as possible to trying to optimize
for eliciting a reaction from you
changed what content got amplified
so when they made that change political
parties across europe on the left on the
right said hey
we know you changed the algorithm
because it used to be we could share the
bread and butter of democracy like a
white paper on our agricultural policy
and it didn't get the most comments but
we had seen the statistics it got read
and now if we share that exact same
content it's just crickets
it's because the algorithm now says
unless we can provoke a reaction from
you it's not good
and when you combine that bias in the
algorithm that extreme content gets the
most distribution
with linguistically diverse places like
the most fragile places on earth are
often linguistically diverse
that means they're using the most
dangerous version of facebook you know
no safety systems because facebook
doesn't think there's enough people that
speak that language and societies are
already fragile
and so it's just very dangerous and
we've seen
more and more times where that gets
weaponized in a context that leads to
tragedy i mean it's safe to say with
with other this assertion and other
assertions facebook does not agree with
your view obviously i'm sure it says it
you know you know the idea of promoting
hate that's just not what advertisers
want so why would they do that it
doesn't make sense for business and that
they don't do that and also with some of
the issues they recognize them and
they're working on them so what's
interesting is we really need to
understand that facebook is not a single
product that facebook in different parts
of the world are very different
experiences
like when there's a multiple hundred
page report from the un
that talks about how facebook was used
by the junta and myanmar to inflame the
genocide like this is not a matter of
contention like it's been very well
documented
um facebook spun up war rooms in the in
the in lead up to ethiopia because they
knew the roles that they were
were contributing to and they knew that
was a risk factor
and yet they still see themselves not as
a publisher as yes platform
you know there was someone from the
facebook oversight board talking to me
about that hella turning schmidt yeah uh
i mean i don't know if you think that
board is fit for purpose they said they
were very interested to meet and talk
with you you met with them
um do you think it's fit for purpose so
the oversight board is a beautiful
illustration of how effective facebook's
communications department is because
most people hear a name like facebook
oversight board and you're like oh
there's an independent body that can ask
questions about facebook they could ask
is facebook inflaming violence with
algorithms turns out that's not their
that's not even in their remit
that when you look at what they're
actually responsible for facebook spent
120 million dollars endowing a board
that can only look at content censorship
decisions so it's not fit for purpose
it's not fit for purpose and we need a
we need an oversight board that actually
can do oversight on the company or we
need something like the digital services
act which of course come you know
countries around the world are looking
at different ways at this at the moment
i know you've been contributing to that
do you think you've done anything that's
made any changes though
what points towards that
so um facebook has tried to expand
coverage of its language classifiers so
in the fall they
rolled out a different way of trying to
run their censorship system so they
could cover more languages which was one
of my core criticisms was that
non-safety systems exist they were
misleading the public about which safety
systems existed in which languages
facebook could have
released parental controls for instagram
at any point in the last 10 years people
have been begging for even basic
parental controls for 10 years
they rolled out parental controls for
the first time maybe two months ago and
you directly think that's that's linked
to what you i think so talk with you and
showed the a number of major leaders on
the the children's rights bill in the
united states have said that the reason
why their bill is moving forward is
because of my disclosures and i think
pressure like that is part of why they
have parental controls today i mean
because let's talk about um with with
particular reference uh facebook of
course the the parent owner of instagram
i mean
what would you say to to those
individuals who talk about the role for
better parenting the role for autonomy
and looking after young people online
and that not necessarily that should be
the platform should be held responsible
so i'll give an example of how it works
today and i'll give an example of
something that's a really low-hanging
fruit that they could do that would put
control in the hands of kids put in
control in the hands of parents
today facebook has run studies where
they take a brand new account blank
account and they they search for some
pretty innocuous stuff like healthy
eating healthy recipes let's be honest
we could all eat healthier
and all they do is they click on the
first five or ten posts each day and
they follow any hashtags that get
suggested so there's there's no friends
there's no other interest they're just
clicking on it it's just the algorithm
within two or three weeks you get sent
to pro anorexia content and pro self
harm content so that's how the algorithm
works today they're pushing kids towards
more extreme content
what could be happening is facebook
could start asking kids they already
take all the content instagram and make
it into clusters so there's maybe 15 000
topics 100 000 topics they could go and
pull kids they do things like this
already
and say does this make your body image
worse does this make your make you feel
bad about yourself and if they saw a
child who was consuming
a thousand two thousand pieces of
content a day that were about topics
that make kids depressed or make them
have worse body image they could ask
that kid do you wanna keep looking at
this content or do you wanna see less of
this content because children are saying
today
i'm working with this therapist i'm
trying to make better decisions and the
content follows me around instagram
like i have to give up my friends to be
be safe
and i think that's like too high a bar
but it if my child was watching a
thousand bits of content 2000 bits of
content that takes quite a lot of time
i would hope i knew about that in some
way that might sound very naive my
child's pretty young at the moment but
there is also that role there i suppose
that some worry that by putting it all
on the social media company without
perhaps even going against what you're
saying here that that role is being
downplayed or ignored so i think one way
to look at is i think good parenting
plays a vital role but one of the things
we need to keep in mind and i lived with
this experience when i was a teenager
you can feel confident about your
parenting but you need to ask the
question are the parents of every one of
your kids friends are they being as
attentive or is every kid is every
parent in your kid's school being that
attentive but i think it's an uphill
fight because these products are
designed to be sticky to be addictive
because they work they're more
profitable that way i suppose there's a
difference between knowing something is
bad and keeping going with it because
it's good for business
and thinking perhaps there isn't or
aren't that many things you can do to
change it
which is it with mark zuckerberg
i think it's a question of um
i think mark struggles with so like i
think he genuinely believes that
facebook is just a mirror
right that that you know there's always
been bad things in the world they've
always been kids with eating disorders
they've always been because they've been
bullied you know this is just a mirror
and and you're unhappy because you can
see it now
and he has trouble acknowledging his
power or the power of these products
but you'll say he just sees it as a
mirror rather than he knows that's doing
harm
i think it's the thing that he tells
himself a story that he's surrounded by
advisors
and they're not telling him and they're
saying no no the world has always had
bad things like it's just a mirror it
sounds like a cult it is a little it it
definitely has some management issues
if you were mark zuckerberg do you think
you should be able to sleep at night
um i think he's really stressed right
like i think the fact that he has this
vision that we're all gonna live in the
metaverse or i think about that a little
bit like the metaverse was a dystopian
concept in the original novel right like
people's lives were so bad that they
went into these virtual spaces
i bet it's really hard for mark to go to
a restaurant like can you imagine people
like looking over and glaring at you
do you think that they do that i think
they do like in silicon valley people
are not pro facebook i mean you sound
like you're sympathetic to him and yet
at the same time you couldn't sleep
because of what you knew and you didn't
obviously know everything i think hurt
people hurt people and i think mark has
been surrounded by people since he was
19 years old who told him he was doing a
great job
and so it's one of these things of we
can demonize mark zuckerberg but it's
not going to make him heal faster it's
not going to like when people are uh
he has the power he does
he's the only one who has the power
because the voting structure of facebook
is different than most corporations and
that he holds 56 of the votes for the
company no one but mark zuckerberg can
control facebook right now do you think
he should go i i don't think he i don't
think the company can recover as long as
he is the leader of it and i think the
fact that he doubled down on the
metaverse
when i brought up issues around genocide
like building saying we have enough
people we have enough money enough
people just to hire 10 000 people to
build video games
instead of actually making these systems
safe
i think that's a dereliction of duty i
mean the companies that pays to mention
yeah 40 000 moderators
uh and that you know they're spending
a lot more on this giving more attention
to it but of course as you say you
mentioned the metaverse there's 10
billion dollars i believe to be spent on
that so when my disclosures happen they
increased the spending from about two
and a half two point six billion dollars
per year to five billion a year which is
great simple duration on modern on
safety systems okay and great that's a
step in the right direction but did you
know they bought back 75 billion dollars
of stock in the 12-month period that's
happening right now so they have enough
money lying around to light on fire 75
billion dollars but they could only
spend 5 billion on safety
they haven't they have 10 billion to
spend on video games but they can't
spend more on safety
you talked about of course what's been
going on in different countries and um
the concerns that you had about lives on
the line but there have also been some
some cases i'm not going to name names
um for for reasons that you know are
obvious we're talking about children
here but there have been examples of
children in both the us the uk and i'm
sure elsewhere in the world
where they have taken their own lives
and the parents blame uh you know
facebook this company you know as part
of that instagram they also blame some
other social media platforms i should
say but do you think of with that
particular instance with regards to
young people do you think of facebook as
having blood on his hands
yes unquestionably um facebook's own
documents say
instagram isn't just bad for teenagers
it's not just bad for children because
remember there's kids all the way down
to eight and nine like parents have told
me kids are are using social media using
voice to text
as young as eight and nine um
that
it's not just bad for them it's actually
worse than other forms of social media
because tick tock is about performance
it's about humor it's about doing things
with your friends
snapchat is about faces about augmented
reality
reddit is at least nominally about ideas
right
but instagram is about bodies and social
comparison
so you you do see when those parents
have said what they have said about
their children
you buy what they're saying about the
role of those companies this company in
particular unquestionably like the the
one that broke my heart the most was
there was a father of a child who died
who i got to meet with and he said i
don't know what i could have done
differently i took his phone away like i
saw he was looking at this content i saw
he was getting bullied i took his phone
away and he ran away from home and when
we looked for him
we couldn't find him anywhere was in any
of his friends houses and the reason was
because he fell asleep on a park bench
and he had hypothermia and so i gave him
his phone back
like i don't know what i could have done
differently
and that's what parents are facing they
feel powerless because these systems are
designed to be sticky
they're not designed for children
they're designed for adults
this might seem a slightly odd question
would you ever go back there and try and
improve it and work there i i still
maintain i still encourage people to
work at facebook because it is the most
we have to solve the problem of facebook
but you weren't sleeping when you worked
at facebook
i mean i wouldn't feel like it sounds
like a good job move for it for me if
i'm not having a job i'm not having to
hold those lies in anymore
right but i suppose if you're saying to
people
go
you couldn't make the change while you
were there so the way the thing i always
say to people is
these systems are very complicated there
are currently uh zero classes you can
take anywhere in the world where you
will learn how facebook's algorithms
work or the interconnection of um how
the algorithms work with the product
choices and we need good people to go
into these companies and and and
participate with their eyes open because
the way the world wants it sounds like
they're going to they're not going to
sleep yeah
i i i
i believe we will only get better social
media if we engage in the process of
building better social media so if you
were given the call i would i would go
back
had the call i've never had the call
they don't really acknowledge i exist
they'll definitely know your name um
just looking across the social media
landscape what do you make of it may not
happen but there's somebody like elon
musk trying to take over twitter and
grapple with the free speech issue he's
also talked about
reinstating for instance donald trump's
account what do you make of that and
what he's said so far about free speech
there's some who have expressed concerns
about him elon musk as a person having
this power
you know i think it's so hard to read
elon's actions because he he does so
many um
he he at this at one point and at the
same time he is able to land rockets on
the moon up right yep upright land them
up and down all those things uh
so he must be good at asking hard
questions and accepting hard answers
because if you're in denial on the level
of mark zuckerberg there's no way you're
going the moon okay um
but he also does all these wacky things
on the internet
and so it's this question of like which
is the elon right and so part of the
reason why i'm cautiously optimistic i
don't know is i think once he gets
inside the company and he can see all
the data
and he can talk to the people and get a
more robust picture i would hope that he
would you know there's a lot of things
that i'm recommending are around looking
at behavior over content
because um when we look at things like
saying you know should you have to click
a link to reshare it how long should you
have to have that link open
clicking on a link before you reshare it
reduces misinformation by 10 or 15
these are interventions that work in
every language in the world
and so i'm i'm cautiously optimistic
based on who his advisors are that there
would be an opportunity to do many of
these things and part of why they
haven't been done to date is they cut
off little slices of profit
and so i think there's opportunities to
explore solutions that weren't possible
when it was a public company but you
know well time will tell
have you made friends with other
whistleblowers do you know something i
do know some other whistleblowers is
there a community of you uh they are
very friendly um i wouldn't say that uh
we have that they might be an active
community but i've talked to a handful
of them uh on an ongoing way i wonder if
there's a kind of
you know sometimes when you take a leap
someone else who's taken a leap before
kind of steps in and says i know what
you're going through and you might want
to think about this this and this what's
so interesting is um
um there's one whistleblower who i've
talked to who has has really who took a
very different path to me and they they
want it very alone right like they they
have never accepted any kind of of
supporter assistance
and like i very early on got um or
started working the whistleblowing
lawyer
and they um whistleblower aid throughout
the united states
um and they were incredibly beneficial
in terms of
educating me on like you think you have
made some choices but let me tell you
about the consequences of those choices
right like
i had always intended not to come out
right like that's part of why the
disclosures are so large is that i
wanted them to stand on their own and um
because they were able to take time and
like
talk me through consequences they were
like your identity is going to be the
juiciest story in the world like and and
facebook knows who you are like they
know who pulled the dot like which
documents and whatever i'm sure they
they know who you are and so
um and so i talked to this other person
who had not gone the same amount of hand
holding
um and it's just so interesting you know
every whistleblower is different and the
thing i would encourage whistleblowers
is like always ask for help people want
to help you and you don't have to be
public
i did want to ask how you relax when
you're not blowing whistles and and
keeping data and then sharing it and
trying to
tell the world what you're concerned
about what's keeping you awake you
mentioned cycling
is that the main or what else do you
like to do i love the ocean and so i
have not i don't have my my bike set up
but the ocean is beautiful
and um uh we have snorkel equipment and
there's there's sea turtles
is that not the most wonderful thing and
you can just lay there in the water and
like follow a sea turtle and you're like
nothing else matters
so i'm really lucky that's a beautiful
image to paint i'm sure you've shared
some photos of it on instagram uh i i on
my instagram is only like the pictures
of me meeting people
no i'm not very good at i'm not very
good at ironically i'm not very good at
instagram so there you go that's a scoop
francis thank you very much for talking
to my pleasure thank you
it's been really fascinating and thank
you so much for being with us until we
meet again do take care and goodbye
[Music]
you